in a remote corner of Borneo hidden in a
patch of protective jungle there's a
school for baby orangutans very often we
receive around and they have spent their
whole life in captivity and that they
have never been able to climb a tree
rescued from the illegal pet trade all
of them have lost their mothers in my
sound like you know impossible that no
longer time doesn't know how to climb
but this is how some of the wrong things
come to us they have to learn most basic
things which is climbing a tree
you know this is how this process of
rehabilitation is so challenging because
you were dealing with the wrong with ten
steps don't know anything about being a
long time they have to learn to be an
American and
and some of them are even like afraid of
high
the process of learning is happening
every single day I mean you know we call
it and around in school and it might
sound like a humanized thing to say but
actually this is a real school
the orangutans are learning from each
other the keepers they can only help the
environment so that then they will learn
faster but they will not be able to
teach them they are not really the
teachers what they can do to facilitate
this learning process is make sure that
they spend as much time as possible on
the top of the trees it is basically the
learning process of the school up there
everything else will come
after a long school day it's time to go
home
and this is their school bus
yeah yeah
hold on
these orphans are still too young to
spend the night alone in the forest
hello
they don't know how to find food how to
build a nest or even keep dry in a
rainstorm they still have countless
things to learn before they're ready to
go it alone graduate and one day be
released back into the wild
okay let's go whoa no happy
yeah
it's impossible not to laugh on a run
with them when you spend time with an
around they are very intelligent they
have a lot of feelings very similar to
our feelings it's impossible not to get
attached to them they will try to reach
out to you and they will try to touch
you then we try to be you know hugging
you it's normal that they need some kind
of physical contact don't forget that
this language they are in the first
years of their lives
they spend most of their time clinging
on to their mothers so when they are too
attached to humans they want to get this
comfort from us and you have to learn to
let them go because you have to make
sure that they are not going to be
dependent on you
and that's why you know we try to
encourage them to be together and a lot
of the times they take other bodies and
they are hugging them all the time you
know and they hug each other because
this is comport for them
it will have the chance to learn from
each other until the point when we
consider that they are ready to be
released into the world and then they
are taken to the forest to be released
and every time that you rescued
orangutans is a bittersweet feeling
because you feel good that you have
given this orangutan maybe another
chance but at the same time is hard to
think that every time that we have an
orangutan here it means that maybe one
more orangutan has been killed
the mother has been killed and the many
other languages that we are unable to to
rescue as well might have been killed
what it really breaks my heart is to see
that we are failing to save the habitat
of this orangutan
along with Dan's are refugees in their
own ecosystem in the last two decades
nearly 80% of their habitat has been
burned to the ground at the current rate
of destruction orangutans could be fully
extinct in just 10 years
there wouldn't be any point for me
standing here if there was no hope I
think the reality is that there are many
wrong turns out there and that we are
still in the moment of time we can do
something about it
for these three-year-olds today is a
special day
they've outgrown the nursery
and this morning their school bus is
going to take them someplace they've
never been before
this will be their first day in the real
forest these trees are taller than any
they've ever seen but here they'll learn
to climb even higher and how to build a
nest for the night
for these orphans a new chapter in their
lives begins on the road back to the
wild
Oh
you